je vous aime bien les gars mais on
enlève son chapeau et on crache pas
quand on croise une
dame c'est quoi cette camelotte c'est un
po très
ancien de
l'ancien
[Musique]
ton un télégram c'est pour ta mère belle
mère je ne veux plus te voir dans mon
salon tu
[Musique]
fais
regardez ce visage buriné par le dur
climat du désert de
L'Ouest soyez les bienvenus à fécity
City on organise un bal en votre honneur
prince une douchesse avec des Bages le
temps est venu Cendrillon tu iras se bal
tu sais bien que si je m'y pointe je me
fais lycher
oh la péteuse qu'est-ce qu' fait
vulgaire prince Vladimir pifpof on ne
parle que de vous en ville vous
inquiétez pas les filles a d'autres
moyens j'ai oublié de lui dire que la
magie s'arrête au 12è cri du
chacal on va le retrouver
C qu'est-ce que vous attendez ramz moi
tout
droit je suis ch debout s amoure tout en
elle respire la féminité la plus
accomplie votre princesse est nul je
vousmets pas à votre place j'vit de
respect c'est
vraiment